do your kids do they get annoyed with
that you're famous they think it's still
cool cuz sometimes my kids think it's
cool but sometimes they're annoyed cuz
they're just like H I think having a a
parent that's well known is very
unhealthy and the statistics are all
there and and and it's like kids just
want to fit in and be normal and then
when you got a dad I mean I I got told
off my my daughter once I was walking up
it was parents evening I got told off
and I and I evaluated my body and what I
was doing and I realized the only thing
I had done was have a pulse um like like
it's just we're embarrassing yeah to
them
what I think I'm cool like like I got my
trainers I got my top like I'm just like
I'm just like I'm just like I'm cool I'm
at school and then the kids and like
they're just so embarrassed and I'm not
cool yeah nobody which breaks my heart
um and and then like you're in the
parents evening and they kind of go um I
did that recipe the other day and um and
then they're like oh no so no it's it's
it's been a rough old ride at times yeah
yeah we just got a battle on yeah we're
just not cool I'm okay with it um do
strangers do they approach you with food
to try cuz I feel like people approach
me with songs yeah I've been given so
many weird and wonderful things do you
ever taste it because I'm kind of like
you shouldn't take a drink from a
stranger at to Bar you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah you don't want to be doped I I
have been given my fair share of like um
like um cookies that have had certain
things put in them but no I I get given
a lot of stuff it's when they say do you
want to try it now oh and they're going
live on Instagram stories and it's like
uh I just had lunch I think oh I know I
have fall on ask people have bought me
stuff too and I'm just like I and I
don't know why well they must think I
love food um but they bring stuff and
I'm I'm afraid to try it but then you
feel bad and I'm like if I get poisoned
and die from this this is how I'm going
to go out you some you got have some
boundaries I know I know I'm bad with
that but in therapy um well
uh well here we go let's do another
commercial break uh Jamie is cooking for
us later in the show because I'm just
always trying to learn his new book five
ingredients Mediterranean is out now
it's really awesome you should get it
I'm going to try recipes from it no
doubt I'm going to post them and
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home